all right hmm Chenoa starts this podcast
with a clap now it's Wednesday we're
gonna do a short but sweet one here guys
I gotta go to New Orleans and oyb I'm
doing a movie with Megan Fox Josh
Duhamel and some other people and for
Megan Fox in a while well you're about
to you know what she made she made one
of my favorite movies no I think it's
called Jennifer's Body
she's an astonishingly beautiful woman
and I'm friends with her husband so of
course I cannot gonna try you know I can
let your hands roam my hands are out I
must warn you my hands tend to roam
she's a mother now yeah when you sit
next to somebody go I must warn you my
hands have a mind of their own
forgive me my dick likes to sniff around
that's right I must apologize but my
hands which other great movie she's evil
I'm not just high school evil oh by the
way I saw a movie really oh no it made
me laugh I watched last night was um
Jason Bateman and all paths no game
night I've never seen it it was kind of
funny
Jason Bateman so Larry he's he is
hilarious
we have to get him on the podcast he's
so fun hilarious he's got a great sense
humor I told you when I auditioned for
him one time he was directing this show
that I actually ended up getting no I
didn't get he wanted me but so you
didn't have him I I I come in with a
suit and it was like this Gucci suit
that that was you I would break break
out periodically and I'm talking like
that and he's like oh yeah great great
yeah and then with there's a whole room
full of executives and he goes now when
do you have to have that suit back yeah
it's like that dry and I go by three so
we have to get this but I thought so I
started he's he's a he's a [ __ ] gene
he's so well you're talking about a guy
who's been acting since he was zero you
can't compete with cut childhood actors
it's like childhood boxers like you know
I feel like some of the childhood actors
though they
some jaded right and they don't and they
also peter out they also fizzle out cuz
like [ __ ] such a hard business or
there's people like what's her name the
literally one the beast when we stars in
the world the hunger games was named
Jennifer Lawrence Jim Lawrence had zero
acting and just she's amazes habit she
was in that movie the first movie I ever
saw and not rust and bone it was x-men
now first movie she ever did was a
really good movie and you could see it I
remember watching her she was 17 okay
she's watching her old camera she would
hold frame like she would she was one of
those people it sounds really weird but
I for actors getting them did not move
not to do anything and she was so still
on camera at 17 and I was like well I
can't do that and I've been acting
forever so I don't know how she does
that [ __ ] I'll tell you another one is
Emma Stone is a kill they said with
Jennifer what was her name warrants
Jennifer Lawrence she was on Marc
Maron's podcast she's pretty great on
there flirtin was marked a little bit
but they were saying that she was saying
in the way she got a first big movie
role a shot dish for the part in LA and
then I can't we don't know if you're
right for it and then they're gonna have
more auditions in New York and they're
like you know we're gonna pass she flew
on her own dime to New York and showed
up was like come on I'm the bum right
for the drive like holy [ __ ] this boat
for Atlantis she took a red-eye from LA
to New York landed when they got there
and it was just stood in line which got
to like whoa
didn't we just see yesterday now she's
like I'm telling you this is for me yes
he said that kind of a success in being
a movie star on her level is not an
accident it's not an accident what they
do is they walk into the room and they
become their undeniable it's exactly
like my friend when he auditioned Heath
Ledger for his movie in fact I'm going
to do is movie now kill he broke his
letter and 10 Things I Hate About You
and when he walked in he goes oh that's
the go oh oh you're 18 oh you got the
job he walked in and didn't start
talking to them and did it yeah and and
he goes yeah that's the guy and somebody
said boy you're pretty confident he goes
well you know why I know that you're
gonna like this because everybody all
the women here are are twice his age and
all of you want to [ __ ] them true or
false and
oh I and I'm a straight guy never sits
down right again and they fought from
your friend of mine yeah I don't mean to
spread rumors but yeah you're good
though yeah look at him
are you excited to do your yeah it sucks
he died are you excited to your movie
being been iMovie setting up hot man
it's been a hot minute but that time
went uh what movie was that that you're
in went to the red carpet and we didn't
know and they fried along no they cut
you out of it ride along it was good you
were in ride-along a bunch yeah who's
some other movie Oh with Kevin Hart
not right now really about last night
last night I loved that movie and I
receive Tony Jeffries went with you to
the premiere for one second for one CD
blank and there it is
you really and what yeah great movie
though this morning love that movie that
was really good
um but you haven't been on a movie set
in a hot minute huh by choice I'll be
honest with you would you say a lot of
it by choice I'll be honest you haven't
barely been auditioned doing anything
yeah a lot of it's been I got my podcast
I got my stand-up and I got my TV show
and I don't have room to squeeze a
goddamn thing in there including a movie
unless you were like the next Batman or
some [ __ ] you know what you know you
might be honest and be Robin I'll be
honest watch your words here we go
I wouldn't know I would turn down but
Batman you're full of it think about it
know what if they if they're like hey
we're doing the real life Peter Pan we
want you to be Tinkerbell the human
Tinkerbell but mail form you doing it
you would do it I did that too um my
wife was horrified because I don't know
why because I'm I get tired of being
aggressive and in charge you ever have
that oh I don't really go this so you
like to get [ __ ] on the bottom I don't
like that no I don't so thank you for
filling in the space but I had people
over who I didn't know that well and
which is maybe an instruction she gave
me an instruction to do something it was
like make sure you're home so that the
kids when they're from 4 to 7 and I was
just tired of solving problems I was
tired of being in charge and I was tired
of being a guy man you
man you know you're tired of being the
general of the count I was tired of
being a man and I and I this is no bull
she tired of being the heavy one
yep and all sudden I went my little tail
and I began to rub my butt against it
oh snap me teeth slap my [ __ ] them bad
feet me and strawberry than slobbing and
I want to poo and I don't know what I
was doing I started hopping in a circle
was she like you're crazy she was like
you are so unattractive I was like I
know punished me for being a lucky bunny
no one was I tried to feed me a [ __ ]
strawberry I actually have in our video
shoes and then I had hunter tail pace
fed me a strawberry mom and I began to
eat it like that now the guy who's ooh
this guy named Reed nice wonder who
comes from [ __ ] Oh God he's got a
really funny show I want to talk about
called quarrel curiosity but I bring up
cordial curiosity he interviews people
in the middle of Runyon Canyon he has a
desk he's super dry and he asked people
about their belief systems and it's so
[ __ ] funny right there look he'll ask
people like he'll ask them like do you
believe in God and he'll just get dudes
on their hike and the way he does it
like there's no not a lot of people
watch it no watch it do I love people
what they should it's so funny watch
this watch this
thank you so much for watching hey did
you know this is about this time your
podcast no trying to plug no no no
here's one no he he does he's the
engineer back pushes watch right watch
this this is so funny
hiked up to the observatory or the park
yeah this is my every week plan every
Saturday every Sunday morning no
judgment so yeah I'll just let you pick
a topic something really think is true
it's so stupid kid in the background
help yeah yeah yeah yeah any type of
belief related to health he never raises
his voice never ever god this is tough
no I'm telling you it's so funny look
look he puts a pumpkin what it is I'm
serious in my experience because I had
lost 150 pounds
oh wow so I don't know if that's
something you're interested to know
because people are what I believe
she never moves in space in a country
was just a guy bride you got to see it
you got gorgeous it's it's just [ __ ]
funny the way he does it
like you can say the crazy [ __ ] to him
and he goes like this he goes oh cool
and then he'll lead people into these
he'll lead these people into like a
quagmire and it's great really smart
really I don't even know why I brought
our buddies hilarity anyway anyway yeah
it's dad Oh dad it's his dad owned a
coal mine and his mom worked in a coal
mine there's great there's both sides of
the tracks crazy man
cordial kids showed a time I started
laughing so hard no he doesn't he
doesn't care about that
like he's not that he just does it he's
got his own weird thing going you know
it's gonna take the world by storm uh
anyway you know who I saw last night uh
the Silver Fox what was his name was
heart McGowan court McGowan Court bring
him up chin Miguel if court Miguel he's
a comedian where we're at the Comedy
Store doing stand-up last night if me if
Brian and him that if they do a remake
of the Step Brothers it should be court
McGowan and Brian caringly good-looking
oh he's a silver fox they kill our Tebow
cor T yeah who they brought up the rail
areas and those aren't even good
pictures of them
this here's way better now it's here
straight backward
we got on podcast cuz he just [ __ ]
guys got great stories just a man's made
he's a man's man he smokes he plays golf
he's from Oklahoma he's make me laugh so
hard last night and then and then feel
Vaughn goes dude you look like you look
like somebody's new step daddy [ __ ] who
[ __ ] the hot daughter yeah look at him
yeah he's a handsome son of a [ __ ] man
couldn't by the way you're talking about
the guy's been smoking for 30 years and
still looks like that like he's got good
genetics he still smokes I don't know I
hope not he said he worked for playboy
for a long time yes he did yes he did if
you think the playboy girls didn't like
him you're sadly mistaken sir
he's been neucom me for a hot second huh
yes he has and then he was a though
there there's a that's a go back that's
how he looks now look at that dimepiece
you and him just need to you know what
you and me to get a timeshare but I'll
both get a divorce I know if he's made
yeah just just never than a passive kind
of young girl yes in Venice but what
happens we'd be in clover silver fox
trap we'd be two old guys with the robes
on and our skin we'd get be getting like
like little marks taken off our skin I
out of cassis thing I got it I don't
know I don't know if he well though be
he has better skin than you yes in here
is here it's better in my ear yeah I'm
smoking there's a set here on them yeah
again not eating well smoking and his
just genetics like [ __ ] I'm going I'll
be a scratch golfer
he's a scratch golfer yeah he goes bro I
used to dye my hair he goes I used to
dye my hair he goes and I just leave it
Silvius Jake to take it man yeah Oh cuz
your daddy uh-huh
your silver-fox daddy oh yeah we we had
some we had some times in Vegas
we had some times yeah what were you two
doing in vase the other shows we were
doing the I'm glad you asked we were
doing the Playboy show so what we would
do you mean the poet is well at the
palms the Playboy Club the Playboy Club
would put on a comedy show oh and they
would have a Playmate of the Month or
the year who would host it and I would
come out or that she was for trying what
would open and I would come out and I
would close I would
and then after I just go to bed and like
you know what did you go get a meal and
go to bed more did you gift everyone
your 40 year old taykitty Hawkins now
take it easy now take it easy I would go
I would I would find myself sometimes up
at the Playboy Club we'd have a meal
I was you know and I would and we would
just hang out with these lovely Playboy
there may have been they may have been
some what's called bunnies around and
then what did you may have been some
bunnies a few carrots my carrots I mean
sir bunnies like carrots that's all you
need to [ __ ] know they love bunnies
neat like they love over Terry you
really loved like okay the SUV do they
love older kids they like they like a
carrot look they like a carrot that's
been in the ground for a while that they
like older okay okay here's the thing
you want it you want to shave baby
carrot with a frown or you want to mmm
big old barnacled carrots been in the
ground a long time I want the bomb
toilets with a stalk when it's long with
a big green star add decon bugs bunny
love yes and when you bite into it
explode yep and and it's got it's got
some marks on it it's got some marks on
it could see something son it's been
around because it belongs to Danny all
right inside to guess that it probably
has a few dots on it sure of course it's
got dots I'm gonna nose burps well it
doesn't hurt but but who knows what it
knows many like David when he pulls out
a barnacle a wart or a mole who knows
who cares yeah but maybe when you pull
that big old carrot out of the ground it
has a drip you you'd be right yes well
it's got dirt marks it's got it's got
zipper marks now does it have dirt marks
because it was going through the
backdoor of these bunnies well look man
I'm not gonna get into the details of
what cuz I know what I heard these
bunnies in Vegas and only bunnies in
Vegas like it out the back and in the
front some some bunnies some bunnies
like to get somebody and then somebody's
like three carats if you catch my drift
what's everybody three carats s1 bunny
half a fete a bunny hole
they got a bunny hole in a bloody mouth
and two bunny hands and I'll watch out
for them to tell some callers party
yeah now listen listen you guys had some
wild times do you want do you like
laughing and eating mature carrots who
doesn't like that
hey dude you want to look you want a
frown or do you want to laugh you want
to know a B you're like those little
your little little carrots that you get
in the store in the prepackaged I feel
like well they widdle those down I think
apparently those are shitty carrots that
they whittle down really yeah they don't
really look like that now I buy the big
old stop Rambo I want to look at a
mature carrot I want to see a big strong
carrot I don't know why right now I love
carrots me too
they good for your eyesight yeah yeah
you should suck my car that's what my
dick it's been soaked and then run out
wrung out with two strong hands he or
took his too strong Russian hands wrong
that sides good man let it [ __ ] Sun
and let some fire and oh God looks like
so injured that turreted Indian rug burn
through the last two years not done that
looks like someone who'd [ __ ] a fire
ant hole Oh looks like do you yeah
you've been [ __ ] a fire ant hill I'm
gonna that's to be a hard pass for me to
put that carrot in my mouth look at that
thing there's yours in quartz carrots
bring up ugly dicks oh sorry I see you
know it you're out of control
I'm out of control we're just it's cool
to brethren sit here type in ugly dick
I wouldn't mean I would look once and
then we'll move on oh gosh I'm just
curious
it's not a no big deal that is the
ugliest kid I've ever seen there I take
mine for like that one yeah oh wow sure
that one looks like a slug yeah
[Laughter]
that's a rat the rats are cute aren't
thank you well I'm a rifleman when I was
with my girlfriend and Joe Jana more you
know Georgiana more made a fortune
riches [ __ ] oh yeah yeah and Joe's a
tough guy and and you know my girlfriend
and me and him were in Washington DC and
he was we were both 19 or whatever and
the huge rat came out of the corner and
then turned around and walked back in
and he jumped on her back you grabbed
him around she my girlfriend Cece who
was a big girl best body on the planet
big body on the planet
now she was whoa well you know what she
looked like you know what her body was
like Brooklyn Decker okay in fact it
laughs at Brooklyn Decker lies inside
our body up I'll put her body up against
anybody who's ever done Sports
Illustrated you know the craziest party
on the planet the craziest body on the
planet and and yeah
anyway so he just got scared of the rat
that's a terrible story he jumped on her
back she grabbed him and she ran up the
steps some people have a phobia of rats
I don't get why you don't you have
phobias of IFO beers of tarantulas I'll
never know that nothing with oh my god
that's Master Splinter that's fake
though it's exaggerating I celebrate a
rat there's a doc on Netflix about rats
you know they're in New York alone
there's some like over 40 million rat
I'm sure underground in New York yeah my
boy you know rats are so sophisticated
that you know how people put out poison
they find it in like they would trick
them with the poison the food so what
the older rats would do is they'd send
the young ones to eat it and if they
died then they wouldn't eat it they move
on Wow they're very smart
the older right like rats have been
around a long time so they'd leave out
food and put poison it and the older
ones tell the younger ones now go try
that food yeah go eat man seriously and
they died like no don't eat it and
they'd move on Wow yeah they're very
smart well it's dr. John my buddy see
sucker owned bought a building in New
York City and they found out that they
had a rat problem well you don't want
them problem it was no no dude Jimmy
Perkins tell me they poison these rats
they were in the walls he was walking
out with garbage bag of Raffles of rats
you know rat garbage I know they found
rats have diseases that it that they
care that would kill humans yeah that we
can't cure so if you well they bubonic
plague they have a bunch of stuff that
if we if we were to get it we hunt a
virus and they don't they left fine with
it yeah I think they have hunter virus I
think all three baddies a woman just
died of it I like a cute rat though man
you don't want them rat problems though
like when I was doing that stand-up in
Mall America Minneapolis in the back
she's like be careful to my son I ain't
scared of no mice I like my celebrate
those I laid on the ground scare me bro
phobia no I'm not scared of really I
have healthy phobias crocodiles tigers
bears that doesn't my phobias poisonous
like if I saw a real one but I don't
like see on TV and I'm like you know if
people get scared if they can't see the
spiders or whatever yeah I'm not video
that stuff see riders don't bother me if
a wasp it's a wasp to use your reference
as a six-pack I like a real war or not a
mic or not day I will drive be not so
much no I wasyou [ __ ] it out of there
or not to FRA or not taste scare that's
the thing couldn't we do without
hornaday's they can't kill bees everyone
thinks you can kill bees you're a [ __ ]
they pollinate the world and you need
them for the doses from all that but or
not days don't do that they just
basically do pollinate and in fact bees
are not even close to in fact bees are
number like 44 on the on the pollinating
we need them they're very important they
are but so are a lot of other things and
gnats flies lots of other animals it'll
pull it like I'm laughs I'm a scarab
dude you ever seen those those Japanese
wasps like going to be having just
returned kill 30,000 at a time six of
them kids kill 30,000 they'd it's a it's
a massive
thing why are they pull on the zone
that's not that terrifies me look at
those things that's really scares it's
freaky
I like swatting a bird and it's gonna be
the size those [ __ ] seriously I want
one there's a pet wish you want as a
mascot in here dude you can let that
thing crowd you I would not I suppose II
let's have more cuz they're ballsy well
what was our boy's name like the kid the
kid who let all that [ __ ] bite him on
the nuts and stuff Carl Cody Cody coyote
coyote cloudy don't down under yeah
coyote coyote with me here chin putting
coyotes Safari guy well Peterson toady
Peterson can to my stand up yeah yeah
yeah but he lets all that [ __ ] by them
yeah
what if he's ever had one of those
Japanese washed by them that weird gig
right now it's a weird gig to get where
you got to kind of keep up in the ante
mm-hmm you don't want to get stung by a
trash la hawk I don't know petting and
playing with giant Japanese Hornet
that's crazy but you know it's like
poison snakes people will let you do
that people will do that because they're
like oh come on dude seriously seriously
look if you just play with that guy
though come on dude what's he doing
maybe they took the sting around no you
just trying to get bit leave this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I mean what are you doing doing it for
the gram that's that's so I think just
trying to survive that's so I started
you see me with my hair I feel bad for
the Hornet [ __ ] this guy no leave that
Hornet alone damn listen to his little
spinners though he's why is this thing
biting him he'll know man okay chewing a
bro to the guy as soon as he bites him
he must think that he's not a threat
it's not a threat to him it's weird but
we're not things don't die once they
sting you like bees right well I think
they can keep pumping yeah they keep on
it keep pumping you and they but they
don't and their stingers don't stay in
yeah and then they get the [ __ ] out of
there I think summers are coming and
we're not days come out when the weather
gets nice but they're not generally
aggressive right I don't think any of
them are aggressive but if you have
something like a nice treat maybe a cake
pop from Starbucks in your hand it
starts to melt they'll attack your hand
they will yeah yeah they'll attack your
hand but you know like poison snakes
some people hold the poisonous ain't
gonna go the trip the snakes aren't
gonna bite the branch it's on that's
full of [ __ ] I said in the face and you
die yeah
oh is that what the snake told you yeah
thinking about the and also you're not a
branch so you're armed they know it's
not a tree they're not that students
right don't [ __ ] around with poisonous
snakes please it's like Costa Rica my
kids are playing in the garden and so
are my friends case I go all right the
guy goes the gardener goes listen their
affair to Lance I've caught some fertile
lands here oh hell no yeah and they have
the boom slangs I think they're called
you don't kill an ox yeah even after you
SWAT the be away a cluster of nerve
cells coordinating the muscles with a
stinger left behind other stinging says
the Yellow Jackets Hornets don't die
when they steam these insects have a
special sheath that slides over the
barbed stand disengages the hooks hooks
are in you yeah and then they just dip
out and then leave that little needle
mm-hmm hurts that hurts those centipede
horned centipedes Hornet sounds scarier
than wasp but
same thing I think no they're not or not
days and wasps were different is that
true
there's different types I thought how
about I was white you know I love making
afraid they do naked afraid extreme
right now they bring back people who
failed or that did well I was watching
that
I don't know if you and I would make it
21 days they were New Orleans they did
the swamps of New Orleans 100% [ __ ] you
will the girl who's one survivalist you
have to just walk they're wet all town
they have to build a bed that's above
the water but the girls laying there and
she goes oh she goes oh my god this is
terrible
the the the insects I'm just the worst
eaten alive and she goes there's no way
I'm out three days was I'm out in the
guys I'm out too no Yuki's no way they
were just you your worst your ass in my
ass we get so yeah just mess whomps in
noir and in Louisiana I've seen people
in Brazil they've been in worse part
better parts in Brazil but the swamps in
New Orleans like the deep deep swamp
where there's Gators there's water
moccasins and then the bugs that's those
devices look at that look at their other
bodies get so eaten up that's nasty
oh my gosh there's a foot there let me
see you wanna see it yeah oh yeah that's
maybe a snake bite yeah I just think
might damn a snake that's a terrible yes
that's not I make it afraid though
that's the problem that you're afraid no
one's ever been hurt there's been no
animals there's nothing so I mean
nothing ice want one person get [ __ ]
up by Tigers so your fate you got your
foot look at that girl's side of her ass
or back we got the second one
leave that oh my god the bugs just eat
you alive man
no that's horrifying if you give me bug
spray I'll do this show even then it
doesn't work you don't think so no after
a while doesn't they stay out of Mother
Nature is always a [ __ ]
yeah but people like Native Americans
got through they're just fine they had
thousands of years to sort of adapt and
they still know to avoid they still
don't yeah but they knew what to avoid
they had resistance so when I was in
Indonesia I went into the rainforest and
and tracked orangutans for I think 11
days yes the Dayak the indigenous people
of in
of the forest the Dayak they they didn't
sweat the way we did not even a little
bit and insects just didn't bite them
because they had evolved to have that
different yep
and uncle that sweet was really amazing
was when they would walk I noticed
and well well I didn't but the woman but
it to the other guy said now watch when
he walks he won't break a twig under his
feet and when you're walking erect when
they walk they there are two things that
you notice one is life happens a hundred
feet up in the rainforest nothing on the
ground really that's where all the food
is so when you watch him they would walk
with their their there they'd be looking
in the up we'd be looking down and
crushing everything and he's making a
racket she she made a stop she goes now
watch the Bible and he would walk and
you wouldn't hear him walking first of
all he's in bare feet second of all he
didn't break a twig under his [ __ ]
feet and it was wild and then the fly I
went to take a pee pee that long feet
they were they were smaller people were
fierce looking sad I agree of the day I
hang out the front no never no they I
got to be friends with him some doctors
or that buzz well when I got lost in the
jungle I I went in took a pee-pee and
got lost and I could hear them and I
still didn't know where I was I got lost
and he just cared he came and found how
do you spill a Brian aya yeah Dayak
people write down their ta y aka the
indigenous people and they were they
were headhunters they would some of the
grandfathers then still then had still
hair from people that they had killed in
in wars with other tribes Jesus yeah on
their dagger pretty well and then I
danced and drank rice wine with a with a
shaman and I was up all night dancing
and you uh singing what tasted me the
fruits of the village glad you asked to
ask now there was I was more interested
in the 28 year old scientist and I was
showing groomed him I was showing her my
wheel kick and and I was with my sister
and I go to her I go she goes where do
you live I live in DC and she goes cool
huh yeah he's come
sometime here there by the way she was
married and that and she goes what do
you do there I go right now I'm kind of
probably gonna work at the bank and my
sister my sister the grenade we call her
the grenade she goes
alright DC yeah he's in college and my
dad pays for everything
took my wheels block off I was like what
but within disorder a wheel kick she was
like wow but with the villagers they
don't use the gringo so so you live
basically so why do you have on rice
with a little tiny bit of fish and some
paste some right I know it was they not
liking you and you're just you have to
mine other girls who was very [ __ ]
cute cute Indonesian girl like me she
was a little smiler and adorable look at
how cute they're a little smiler
yeah she belong to the head does she
belong to one of the bad [ __ ]
one of the dudes who carried a knife
could you talk to him you would've gut
me he would have got me I feel like I
still risk it all though my friend uh
back then and yes yes I would I'd risk a
gutting for a little how do they do it
do they have multiple women there is it
no they're pretty monogamous they they
have traditional kind of situations but
oh wow that grandma's hot not that one
no there I feel bad there are beautiful
people the third row but the fourth
picture and the yes please mama Coco's
hot mama coca has been around a long
time and she stretches those years how
about my girls grandma staying with us
when I say shouldn't speak a lick of
English
I mean after use [ __ ] sign language
to figure things out with Gavin nothing
she comes from the hardcore Guadalajara
Mexico and it is struggle city was
jumping her I have to take her by the
hand and just yank her places you know
she's about oh five nine four nine four
nine small woman not a lot of milk drunk
and you're a giant I like those shoes
there I said I don't thanks man just
wife Jana was wearing those well not in
this color
they have women's
color but yeah okay who makes those bro
Valentino these aren't for you these are
not for me I'm just a little too old
that's a fact but there's much the boots
on them where I'm at - boots know how
nice what - boots amazingly my favorite
kicks amazingly comfortable when did you
can I wear these with a suit from the up
front
please don't I want you to be taken
serious okay so I wear my if you have it
the only reason I don't like those
through this suit do occasion go suit
will cause your suit blue like the same
blue yeah but I have I have our I have
my other ones were they were they called
the expensive ones your booty cuz the
sneakers that you were that you
introduced me tell me project common
fraud color they're kind of a gray blue
so those will go
that should work I don't like it it's
almost too chill cuz I don't like the
white bottom with the suit okay I like a
white bottom of the suit could do it has
to be tailored right shoot some current
event and I get going man it's just your
hands man so there is one current event
that's really really terrible
should we just bypass it it hasn't me
with a leopard and a kid that just
happened to get on yeah what happened so
I was talking about yeah we got to find
out it's terrifying
so this is a national Ugandan national
park a ranger was doing his thing and
left his kid with the the nanny there at
the facility and then I guess the nanny
was walking outside and the kid followed
her and she didn't realize it and then a
leopard snatched the kid Yeah right the
next morning they found only a skull
remaining yeah the kid dead just like
that from the leopard sure that's where
that happens with mountain lions and
kids too so when it's okay Mountain Lion
Area and so confused hold on be let's
focus on your hold on so what so why was
there a wild [ __ ] leopard it's in
it's actually in the safari park but
their walk away they just walk around
I'm sure that they said is unfenced area
so sure you could just walk around with
love when you know because when you're
in in a like a range like that lepers
don't come in they stay away from people
even if you're so if you're
in our in an area so when you go on
safari with tents the animals stay away
from you at fits people they stay away
but in this case probably a hungry
leopard sees a small child which is prey
about the woman though the woman tend to
lead the world vote they here's the
thing that here's the thing about a
leopard and here's thing about any cat
like that you don't hear it mm-hmm you
don't hear that leopard come up and grab
that kid you don't hear it that leopard
comes up it doesn't go out like in the
movies that leopard comes up clothes
jumps on it grabs it and runs off you
don't have a chance it's like a six year
old was between his mom and dad in
Colorado and some other people they were
hiking and a mountain lion jumped out of
the bushes grabbed that six year old and
ran off with them yeah that's amazing
they would they like it happens so
quickly nobody could do anything I feel
sick yes yet big big cats can do that
men big cats do that terrible Uganda
last thing on this so they said that
they have to remove to definitely kill
that line or sorry the leopard because
they said once it tastes human flesh
it gets really dangerous like they might
be tempted to taste it again that's
right all right so onto something more
funny that you posted on Instagram the
50 cent calling out Rampage Jackson what
do you mean it's almost the fight
Rampage Jackson remember like we talked
to below the belt
I'm Scott Coker just signing a contract
with 50 cent is in fifties like
something bigs happening and then
eventually 50 posted that he wants to
fight rampage for the right amount of
money and then so it looks like it's a
possibility as crazy as it sounds it's
not what is this then it's it's just
it's I think it's just 50 cent strolling
he never would remember 50 cent before
he came on a show he's trying talking
about boxing he's a guy did some boxing
Golden Gloves I was going to lift champ
try my box I'm like oh well you know
where did you box out what what district
all that stuff he can answer those
questions remember that yeah and then we
were on the show and I went well you've
done some boxing is all remember that no
he is no background in fighting nothing
okay yeah I think he was beaten with uh
with Scott Coker he said that he got in
a tussle with them
boy boy everything and he said the
punches came so fast that he couldn't
believe it my foot hitting my three
times before you know what the [ __ ] was
going on yeah well yes for never calls
me out yeah I I did saw it's just all
smoking where's this this is not
happening
you don't want any part of also no
Commission would sanction that fight
ever think about it if you just think of
the logistics the details no Commission
would ever sanction that fight rampage
how many fights does he have home world
champion and pride former world champion
the UFC we're gonna fight a rapper 50 is
in shape he's younger he's fast and
rampage he's older but rampage has had a
lot of fights he's how old is 50
I'm just work it might as well said you
know warren buffett's fine yeah I will
say this if there's anybody who's tough
is big and tough and strong it's 50 he's
not a rapper and says that baby big and
strong but so I mix it up oxes know you
you think because you hear him rappy
stuff done yeah he's been shot it
doesn't make you tough either he's
because he's black he's tired he's got a
lot of muscle on did know it's all
[ __ ] of course it's [ __ ] yeah
you just like the attention or do
anything like when he taught [ __ ] - you
know he's just constantly talking [ __ ]
yeah Todd's talking [ __ ] trying to stay
relevant fighting rampage no one would
ever sink to the fight I know but still
it's kinda strange about it chin um say
oh no what about CM Punk CM Punk didn't
fight any when he fought CM Punk fought
a guy who was one a No bleep far amateur
at least who did they don't care about
that but but it's better but chin the
way it works is but the way it worked
you can't have a guy with 70 pro fights
funny guy was zero fights yeah but hold
on hold on for a second you keep talking
bring a 50 cent fighting I want to see
if he's hitting MIT so I'll tell you if
he can fight rampage I'm a boxer he said
boxing yeah
I'm sure he's athletic it doesn't matter
again another to these black no no no no
he's big strong he looks at funny he's
not matter he's definitely not a lot of
sport never see them but see he's just
barn with the Sun here oh yeah look at
the footwork
that's just assuming he's athletic
non-athletic wait you don't become a
rapper knocks out somebody no that's
just a son okay so that's the oldest in
sparring his head where what's up right
there 50 Cent's barn it's got a birthing
wow this is row that's that's real [ __ ]
bro that's some real [ __ ]
that's a terrible video no go back
that's him in the gym there with him
Lloyd maybe click on Floyd is that just
him talking oh no where you missed it
where you got to go back do your search
I'm saying that's a 4150 in the gym I'm
sitting here assuming he's tough and can
fight to these black no he's athletic
man and it's just them hanging out oh
dude
excuse me
excuse me you sure it's not good dude
look at him working he's go
that's rampages face bro are you [ __ ]
kidding
oh [ __ ] watch it that's I don't know
dude when you work a speed bag can I ask
you a question what did you speed back
for like that
why do you do that a lot of its timing
and shoulder conditioning wow it's a lot
you gotta stay on it though it's not me
out of practice man yeah do you God but
it doesn't make you a better fighter
no I know wilt the hands coordination
stuff like that yeah some people are
really really good I do ever dig keep
going chance you ever do it to gungeon
alright so there's a a guy in a
correctional officer that was accused of
raping inmates female inmates and then
the jury that had to hear the fema's
talk about this guy we're getting tired
of hearing about his penis because it
was huge and stinky so here's some of
the I'm confused
he worked at the prison worked ever was
raped of female prisoners and so then
he's on trial yeah so and then the
people were raped who kept saying is a
huge stinky dick because they were
giving their deposition or whatever
there is a deposition when they're
telling yes that's what they say about
here's some quotes it was so big I want
to throw up said the 50 year old former
inmate testified through a translator
while explaining how Perez forced her to
perform oral sex on him while he was
working uh and had it has smelled like
he didn't wash or take a shower it was a
really strong smell that guy should die
how can you describe what is this hey
this is cage guys do lieutenant
Perez penis look like she owes it's big
its fat I mean you know you wouldn't
circumcise is big it was like a hook it
was a humongous and it was curved but
read this part this woman actually said
that if it didn't stink I would have
been all over it that's [ __ ] it didn't
say that [ __ ]
hey this is shower and don't be a rapist
you piece of [ __ ]
one of the women was like she felt super
lonely in prison so she kind of like
yes was okay with it sure for a little
while really yeah well I would imagine
that there are a lot of women that would
be all over his big dick if he [ __ ]
washed it and wasn't a piece of [ __ ]
like like like I'm sure some woman and
prisoner down of course they are yeah I
mean here you're not getting any digging
a guy comes in with a giant hot dog it's
Cola but let's not let's not [ __ ] rub
dirt on it and and and let's get
Columbus up our yeah you idiot take a
shower you [ __ ] but you know when you
have a dick that biggie prized to curve
it and it sits in the crack of his rump
er you can't get that and then he
doesn't wipe his butt well so now he's
like an elephant's try that's exactly
right so he keeps it tucked in his crack
god damn it dude clean your dong off you
can't have not move out to the mainland
don't rape women well the thing though
yeah so he screwed he raised women so so
he's being accused of he forced them
against their will basically and they
all the feds made him show his piece
yeah and they all described it to be
exactly what it looks like so he should
doubt if you're the Fed judge we're
gonna see you dick now now I'm now
you're under arrest but I'd like to
shake your hand and buy you a drink
look they have to see it don't they
they're like we got a they said this
spot in the upper left-hand corner of
your car let me see it well my dad my
buddies at a cop who does all this stuff
like deals with big zacapa cases he does
a fugitive cases child pornography and
all and you have to watch all the stuff
for evidence and it sucks I'm a quick
anime one the one I sent you about UFC
streaming deal they finalized it with
ESPN but I just learnt new partner in
the front so they finalized it with us
Ben but the we haven't heard about have
you heard about this be yeah so yes he's
signing to do with the ESPN but see me
on ESPN plus so it says set to launch
now 19 the deal include 15 live UFC
events to be branded UFC on ESPN fight
nights to stream exclusively on ESPN
Plus which is their app their their app
so you can't really get on to it's not
on TV it's not an ESPN sign espn2 so
it's on their app that you have to pay
for it yeah and it's only streaming
streaming but there are they did say
that there would be
some television yes and what happens do
we know what happens with the
pay-per-view that's gonna be the same as
usual like a regular paper and they're
doing the same so this is all for like
the finance the stuff that we would get
on foxsports1 - I think that's all that
stuff that they would now check this out
they're off they're still doing a deal
with Fox as well really yes give me it's
from what I hear is gonna be ESPN and
Fox because ESPN only paid 150 so other
200 mil they need to cover their asses
is gonna come from Fox and so I I don't
get how they can do it I'm sure now let
me ask you this does it feel like a step
back that they're on the app now because
I'll see streaming digital media's the
future the future yeah but doesn't seem
like a step back we're now we have to
get this app I'm freaking connected your
TV but I don't know it's just
it depends what flights they put on
there yeah it does
$4.99 a month is what they currently
cost for that app so that's not too much
which is flight paths I don't even know
I think it's 11 something
$10.99 so $4.99 a month to get that or
49 for the year here's the other thing
I'll ask you how much how because ESPN
right the wide the worldwide leader in
sports
how much promotion is the ESPN gonna
give the UFC yeah I don't know I don't
know if it's a great move I hope it is
do you know anything about you have the
UFC and how they're doing as a business
in comparison let's say last year yeah
they're down for sure no I write down
numbers yeah numbers of death yeah that
that's why this TV deal was so tough for
them to get because you know they when
they bought when WME willing more spot
the UFC for four billion they were
assuming those numbers and the the
popularity of the UFC was gonna continue
to grow and it has not just is their
model now it's it's not a it's not a
problem with the with the Fighting's
never been better
the problem is is their business models
jacked up whether they have to have
superstars in order for people to tune
in what would you do is there is there a
remedy to that yeah the oversaturated
oversaturated sway over saturate so
instead how many fights everybody fights
in too many fights and the cards aren't
that good so if what I would do I would
do six pay-per-views a year and I'd make
it special again those six pay-per-views
with from top to bottom are stacked with
the superstars then Fight Night is for
the young up in commerce that people
watch on TV just like box and used to do
back in the day and that's on Tuesday
Wednesday nights and then pay-per-views
there's only six a year but it's like
the Super Ball man it's packed with the
best of the best and it's a spectacle
celebrities love do but what do I know
it was amazing back in the days yeah it
was so fun to watch that's what I would
do that's fair makes sense to me that la
cards are trying to pack that that one
in August you trying to have TJ Cody do
they want to do guests in Luke Rockhold
and then I'll see the rumors GSP Nate
Diaz that's not happening even though in
just so you guys know and then we can
move on it's a tactic and I don't know
if it's from the USC side it's from
their social media side or it's from
their publicist side but news will leak
to force fighters to think they have
pressure from the public to take a fight
when if they want to fight so let's take
the beat and Yair Rodriguez for example
Yair does not want that fight the others
had a year off he got his ass whipped by
Frank Yeager
he's trying to find himself oh here's a
beat who's probably right should be in
the top three in the world top five he's
a [ __ ] nightmare yeah here's a beat
people want this here's a beat and yeah
guys I don't want that fight no not yet
let's wait till he's ranked higher
before I fight him he's a monster he's
not ranked where he should be
I'm gonna wait to fight him they go
we'll know you need to fight him he goes
nope I won't were you know renegotiate
my contract you want me to fight that
type of dude so but the UFC wants to
fight now the son what do you guys see
confirm the beat Yair fighting it's not
confirmed it's a tactic that they use to
have the public put pressure and then
the ire goes oh [ __ ] man they this is
real people want this I have to take it
but guys are getting smart and smarter
these days
yeah just like GSP Nate done final Los
Angeles big UFC card that's not true GSP
does not want that fight
GSP if he's gonna cut the
fifty-five it's only gonna do it is only
gonna do it to face the winner of Conor
verse khabib which is what's happened in
September from my sources so he's gonna
fight in December he's in GSP go on
listen if I kept 255 it's gonna be one
monster costume I only fight like I have
one more fight to me my only fight it's
gonna be for the biggest fight of all
time and it's no district innate but I'm
not doing for Nate in August that's
enough time for me it's not happening
but what do you guys see GSP Nate going
down it's happening and there's just
pressure everyone wants it right the
public wants it it's an old tactic man
but people buy it they buy but we talk
to people really know it's going like no
God we're so far away from doing that
what the [ __ ] we tried we're trying to
talk and it's not happening right Wow
I love that stuff I love the inside [ __ ]
I never think about that stuff but it
makes a lot of sense yeah you're so when
I tell people my guy ears I beat SWAT
happy I'm not a journalist honoraria
honey my friend that who our agents who
the actual fighters tell me the stuff
and I cool I don't ask for this info why
the [ __ ] would would the UFC waste a
jewel like it's a year yeah year bring
him up slowly
you can't Frankie and they don't look at
it like it's an unbelievably what they I
could be so exciting get like give him
some time so I told let him work on his
wrestling that's right this is a this is
my thing for the fight when I talked to
his agent and I said listen let's just
look at this pros and cons pros you
fight is a beat unless you're a hardcore
fan you don't really know who he is now
he's a [ __ ] nightmare should be
ranked in the top five to be honest
should be ranked top five from Mark
Henry who trains Frankie Edgar Edson
Barboza
and Eddie Alvarez goes he's the most
talented guy 15 walk in this gym the
things he does he is so three gentlemen
I've never seen before
he's a complete freak make sure you stay
on him make sure you watch him carefully
so I hear those things and I go man most
people don't know him though Yair
good-looking kid all see has major
Mexican roots phenomenal striker good on
the ground doesn't have wrestling just
coming off a huge loss of Frankie Edgar
right and it's been out a year when the
fighters out a year that's a red flag
why is he
it's a red flag because he's been broke
he's been ma anytime anyone who's oh
just hanging on Connors nuts no it's
Connor it's Nate Diaz although there's
been this long layoff now there's DC
steep a anytime someone loses of real
fight or let's get back in there
tomorrow they want to be back in the
next because they feel that's not them
something happened they need to fully
redeem themselves whenever a fighter
takes a long time off it's a red flag
they're trying to find themselves
there's holes they're lost they're
looking for answers yeah because he
didn't have an answer when a fighter
takes two years off via Conor McGregor
Nate Diaz well now it's not about
fighting more now it's just money moves
yeah now now the passion for fighting
his gun will still watch him fight and
they stuff huge fights in front of them
but that passion that desire is not
there anymore if you if think you left
stand-up right yeah what if I told you
years on possible you go say [ __ ]
yourself
I mean tampons can't live without them
now filing your true calling when you're
up and coming and you you will fight
every weekend yeah now imagine something
you love so much I take two years off
you would laughing yes so whenever you
see someone take a long laugh of their
so pasión
something is going on he's going this
and a lot of it can be that sort of
thing where is that yeah you're probably
as a young fighter went I don't know how
to solve a problem like Frankie a great
start for a driving a diving double leg
oh why because the tarot master for me
in Frank is one the best 155 all behind
and then cut to 45 yeah I mean what are
we doing why would you do that to him
why and this is what you break these
guys you bring us to where box and get
to right box and gives ire 45 like Frank
that's right not the UFC Oh marketable
here's Frankie yeah it's like it's like
it's like um it's like fodder it's like
you're cannon fodder you're just wasting
young men who like a meat grinder cannon
cannon fodder you know what that means
that expression
cannon fodder is when you would send
young men into the battle and they were
they were basically
cannon fodder they were target practice
for the kanjis so in World War one when
when there was trench warfare they would
just they blow a whistle and you had
charge into what's called no-man's land
into machine-gun fire and the other side
knew you were coming so in in in an area
of less than 30 40 50 100 yards
sometimes literally ten thousand men
would fall it was crazy
World War one look that up I mean it's
not you not today I'm saying the trench
warfare and world war some of the worst
[ __ ] in the world everybody should read
about it to see that what's all around
outlet they would send men into the into
the into the cannons and it was because
they're arrogant [ __ ] generals who'd
met who weren't fighting and would take
eighteen year-old man in Joker's were
we're going to we're going to basically
try to take that land and it was all
trenches so you you would take the next
trench but let me lose though wouldn't
mean and everybody would die literally
and then everybody would die I always
think that the movies were you know back
in the day when they would have like
swords or the muskets and the knives on
the end of there and they'd run at each
other can you imagine me in the front
row be like yeah god damn it that's
right old in World War one if you didn't
you'd get shot you get shot by your
commanding officer on you could not not
refuse it if you need to use it you
would be shot for cowardice if you had
if you had PTSD it's like the amount of
bombardment would put people in the
state of shock and they'd be carried out
maybe like this they move and they shoot
him for cowardice because they didn't
know they didn't know there was a
neurological thing going on with them
they shouldn't know it was crazy
Lawrence but with the UFC we wrap it up
on this move on but I hope the ESPN
thing is a is something good because of
the fire thing and I have no qualms with
Fox I like Fox they there's good and bad
but it's kind of been a failure you know
it's it hasn't worked out when the UFC
I'm in the business to fight business
right I have a [ __ ] TV show on the
fight bin so when they do good I do good
well if they were to go away we all go
away so I want I hope this is good man I
hope they figured out
I hope they realized that they're over
saturating the market they know this
they know this and everyone goes and
everyone goes this is the problem cuz
they're making money off sponsor stuff
like that but the ray
things are down and then they put on all
these shows they're still gonna put on
40 something shows which is ridiculous
to me but they go oh you know we live
and die off the paper you model and we
need superstars but you have superstars
but you're spread anyone so think
there's so many cards just do laughs but
it there they're hungry they're greedy
they're hungry and they have dummy
WME who has no [ __ ] clue about the
fight business right they have no clue
but they want to be like the NFL and NBA
and be on all these networks to put on
these shows and stay relevant and get
their dicks out and show up cage side
with it and we're not we're not the NFL
not the NBA we're never gonna be there
do your thing be different do six major
events all around the world
Russia Dublin China America Brazil and
just [ __ ] make it like the World Cup
man but six of them okay what else yet
are you good on time right now time is
it it is 10:00 right yes sir I was just
getting started I was just gonna have
second gear Brian yeah because of New
Orleans she don't know you drive me no
please
no I'm not you but I'm not your Oberer
try me in your Porsche any $100 what
that's a lot of money dude all right you
make Bank done your daddy yeah hey are
you gonna leave your braces on when you
meet all these fancy people probably not
are you leaving mom when you shoot your
movie don't come braces though their
braces brother clear braces are you
leaving my when shoot your movie you
take money
no I gotta take off come on man why are
you going through Instagram work that's
the perfect time to do an hour before um
oh I mean QR let's wrap this [ __ ] up I
know you're going I'm fired from your
movie because of the show I'm Houston
I'm there June 20th 22nd get your
tickets now p5k calm tonight the
Excitebike be shop stain delaying tour
vintage tees drop tonight 5:00 p.m.
Pacific it's Wednesday right yeah that's
Wednesday by p.m. Pacific t fact k dot
car home
new shirts and merch dropping beat um
we're gonna be a nobody I'm gonna be in
what I just realized is May 31st June 1
June 2009 go to good nights Raleigh
North Carolina June 7 8 good night yeah
good nights Raleigh North Carolina get
your frickin tickets get your tickets
episode 6 below-the-belt TV show drops
tonight well but I'll post it tomorrow
more than Thursday morning I'll drop 4
years it's fun one Charlo brothers some
clips from leslie smith it's a good one
you'll dig it here it's good it's fun
thank you guys for listening this is a
finally kid we're out